hey youtubers is Charlie so Deadpool is
just crushing x-men apocalypse at the
box office so this is gonna be my
Deadpool kills the x-men video and I'll
explain where Deadpool crosses over with
the x-men in the comics so no surprise
Deadpool is the number one x-men movie
of all time
both worldwide and domestic and when I
say domestic I'm talking about the
United States domestic box office but
now a lot of people are wondering why
Fox isn't leveraging Deadpool inside
their x-men movies and Bryan Singer kind
of explained that earlier this year
after Deadpool blew up and everybody
loved it he just said that the tone of
x-men apocalypse is so serious that
pulls so silly
they just didn't mix really well and
he's not wrong you couldn't put that
version of Deadpool in this version of
x-men apocalypse and have it make any
sense he was just completely sideline
the film it'd be an even bigger mess
than it already is and if you haven't
seen my x-men apocalypse video there are
a bunch of problems with the film mostly
that they just tried to stuff too many
things into it in the script wasn't
quite ready they needed a little bit
more work on the story in the stakes are
just a little too high Deadpool on the
other hand just kept things really small
really condensed and it actually helped
the film a lot like it just doesn't get
pulled in a million different directions
like this x-men movie did but one of the
other big reasons why Deadpool hits so
hard with audiences is because superhero
films in general have gotten to a more
mature state so we're at the point of
civil war in Captain America where it
becomes this film about deconstruction
the deconstruction of superheroes and
that's kind of what the Deadpool
character has been turned into in the
last 10 to 15 years originally he was
just created to be spider-man with
swords like he looks like spider-man but
he acts like Wolverine he has a bunch of
swords so then his more riders came on
he started to break the fourth wall more
and more and they started to use him in
a more meta way so it's really easy to
use the character in movies to take the
piss out of the superhero genre like he
pokes fun at the x-men continuity
problems they can't really do that in
the x-men apocalypse film in the same
way but I think what's gonna happen is
is when they get to x-force they'll try
that a little bit more so you'll see a
balance of x-men film and Deadpool film
so that is my prediction for the very
first Deadpool official crossover in the
movies with x-men now technically this
is an x-men crossover anyway because
there's a couple x-men characters in it
but we're really talking crossover
between a less characters so you have
Deadpool crossing over with Professor X
or something like that
Deadpool crossing over with the x-men in
the comics though he's crossed over with
the x-men characters a lot but usually
in the spin-off titles he hasn't
appeared a lot in uncanny x-men or the
proper x-men comics so when you see him
pop up in the comics it's usually like
in Wolverines comics it's in cable and
Deadpool he crosses over with them in
his own comic the first real crossover
with Deadpool in the x-men team like the
main x-men team was in his own title
Deadpool vol 2 number 16 in 2009 so
that's just a little under 20 years
after the character was created that's
how long it took for him to really
crossover with the x-men so if you never
read that story it's basically Deadpool
getting tired of working by himself he
decides he's good enough to be part of
the x-men but the x-men ain't habitant
Cyclops is like no deal no sale we're
not taking you the title of this video
Deadpool kills the x-men and anytime you
hear me reference Deadpool kills xx it's
usually taken from Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe which was this big
special comic book event but it was just
a case where Deadpool goes to an insane
asylum to try and cure his insanity to
clear up the voices in his head but the
person treating him is a supervillain
and it winds up backfiring the voices in
his head tell him he needs to kill
everyone so thus Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe one of the only problems
with Deadpool being rated R and being
what it is I mean it's so amazing I'm so
happy that it is what it is but one of
the problems with that is that China
won't let the film into the country
which means there's more than a billion
people that the movie doesn't have
access to so there's a lot of money that
it's leaving on the table which is why a
lot of films get toned down a little bit
Michael Bay's films are a good example
of films that are China friendly there's
not a lot of talking and there's a lot
of bloodless CG action so that's
typically what you see when you look at
children's programming there is action
but there's not a lot of blood there's
not a lot of killing so China is like
the last great frontier for movies so
Deadpool could have earned way more
money if they would have toned the film
down but then that probably would have
made the film less popular it would have
been as awesome as a film so there are
certain times when it's better that a
film is rated R like this like Deadpool
is perfect rated R so I give the
producers and Ryan Reynolds a high five
for not
chasing that china box office in the way
other big films do and the only other
real consequence of that is that they
have to keep the budget of the movie
down so that's the reason you see a lot
of hundred and fifty million dollar
movies stay at pg-13 so that they can
get into China and get like an extra
hundred million dollars on their box
office but here's the thing even though
x-men apocalypse made it into China I
still think the Deadpool is gonna wind
up making more money especially when you
consider home video sales which isn't
really something important to go into
but that's like a whole other revenue
stream for a movie so sometimes movies
don't make a ton of money at the box
office but they do really well on home
video
so Deadpool is gonna walk away whistling
as the clear winner here
but don't automatically assume that
because of that they're gonna shove
Deadpool into every single x-men film I
do think that the films would benefit
from Deadpool but I think x-force is
probably a better match for him because
they can make that a little more
hardcore I think they want the main
x-men films to be traditional family
fare so something that you would be able
to take an eight-year-old kid - there
were a lot of really funny stories about
people that took like really little kids
- Deadpool in most of those funny
stories it's the parents that freaked
out not the kids like the kids might be
a little confused about some of the
action the parents just become horrified
that I just wish I could have been next
to some young family who didn't realize
that Deadpool was gonna get pegged by
copycat in the film and if you don't
know what that is that's just the scene
where she does him in the butt with a
strap-on there is no universe where
someone is gonna get paid in one of
these main x-men films but that's okay
that's what we have the Deadpool movies
for so let me know in the comments do
you think that x-men apocalypse will
ever earn more money than Deadpool at
the box office and do you have any funny
stories about families that were in the
theater with you watching the movie like
a parent who brought their kids to the
movie because it's a comic book movie
without really realizing why it was
rated R
yay for kids yay for r-rated comic book
movies what's gonna happen next though I
got to see an early screening of
Warcraft it was a lot of fun you'll
probably have a lot of fun at it
especially if you played the game I'll
do a non-spoilery review next and then
I'll post my Easter Egg video later this
week
because it's not gonna be out in the US
for a couple more days so everybody
enjoy your chimichangas while you wait
for me to post that next video you can
click here for all my Deadpool Easter
eggs if you haven't seen that yet and
you can click here
all about Superman actually coming on to
the DC TV shows like a real-deal
Superman so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight